-Performing "Forever"
from her Showtime documentary
"Sheryl,"
please welcome Sheryl Crow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Lay your head down,
don't you worry tonight ♪
♪ Can't fix the world
no matter how you try ♪
♪ Give it some time,
you will find ♪
♪ Everything is alright ♪
♪♪
-♪ There's no such thing
as forever ♪
♪ But you and me,
we've got today ♪
♪ And every moment
we're together ♪
♪ I know there is a heaven ♪
♪ 'Cause you make me
feel that way ♪
♪♪
♪ When I get down,
you're the one that I call ♪
♪ You pick me up
every time that I fall ♪
♪ And when you laugh ♪
♪ Nothing else
matters to me at all ♪
♪♪
-♪ There's no such thing
as forever ♪
♪ But you and me,
we've got today ♪
♪ And every moment
we're together ♪
♪ I know there is a heaven ♪
♪ 'Cause you make me
feel that way ♪
♪♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Garbage out in space,
garbage in LA ♪
♪ Baby, what a waste ♪
♪ Everybody's mad,
everybody's sad ♪
♪ See it in their face ♪
♪ I gotta have the latest ♪
♪ Gotta have the best,
the most ♪
♪ If you wanna be happy ♪
♪ Light a match and watch it all
go up in smoke ♪
♪♪
♪ There's no such thing
as forever ♪
♪ If we get stuck in yesterday ♪
♪ And every moment
we're together ♪
♪ I know there is a heaven ♪
♪ 'Cause you make me
feel that way ♪
♪ No such thing as forever,
no such thing ♪
♪ But you and me,
we've got today ♪
♪ And every moment
we're together ♪
♪ I know there is a heaven ♪
♪ 'Cause you make me
feel that way ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness.